Let's get to the news.
At a rally in Florida
last night,
President Trump falsely claimed
that photo ID is required to buy
groceries in the United States.
Dude, what you eatin'
for dinner? Rental cars?
[ Laughter ]
During the same rally,
President Trump claimed
that he could be
more presidential
than any president in history
"except for possibly Abe Lincoln
with the big hat."
[ Laughter ]
Oh, right.
That Abe Lincoln.
Are you at a campaign rally
or show and tell?
"This is my Abe Lincoln.
He has a really big hat.
And he hates going to plays."
The New York Mets suffered their
worst loss in franchise history
last night, losing to the
Washington Nationals, 25-4.
It was so bad that even
the ceremonial first pitch
was hit for a triple.
[ Laughter ]
That's right. The New York Mets
lost to the Washington
Nationals, 25-4.
It was so embarrassing,
Mr. Met switched jerseys
in the third inning.
[ Laughter ]
President Trump
said this morning
that the Russia investigation
is a hoax, tweeting,
"The Democrats paid for the
phony and discredited dossier
which was,
along with Comey, McCabe,
Strzok, and his lover,
the lovely Lisa Page,
used to begin the witch hunt.
Disgraceful."
And I love that even in
the middle of a meltdown
over the investigation,
he still has time
to hit on a woman.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
"This is a hoax
and a witch hunt and --
Oh, hello, there."
[ Laughter ]
President Trump
also tweeted today,
"Looking back on history,
who was treated worse?
Alfonse Capone,
legendary mob boss, killer,
and 'Public Enemy Number One,'
or Paul Manafort?"
Hey, man, if you're
trying to convince people
you're not a mobster,
maybe don't let everyone know
you know Al Capone's full name.
[ Laughter ]
"Why is Robert Mueller treating
me like I'm a worse criminal
than the legendary
Theodore Robert Bundy?
[ Laughter ]
Sagittarius."
Former President Obama
was spotted golfing yesterday
at a country club in Virginia,
unfortunately by this lady.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Two sets of identical twins are
set to be married to each other
this weekend in Michigan.
But wait. It gets weirder.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new survey,
women are more
sexually adventurous when
trying to conceive a child,
which means you should
definitely not tell your kids
the story of how
they were conceived.
"Well, first, your mom
got up on the swing.
I was dressed like a pirate."
The USDA has issued
a health alert
over premade salads and wraps
sold at Walgreens
due to concerns
they may be contaminated
with an intestinal parasite.
So if you're buying
your meals at Walgreens,
I have even more bad news.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Today was National
Girlfriends Day,
so don't forget
to send her $130,000.
[ Laughter ]